[Music]
[Applause]
let's go around the room the best player
that Clark Kellogg faced in college that
might be hard because you have to
remember who he was facing in the Big
Ten how about his entire career the best
player he ever faced
Todd I'll start with you I'm going to
say Larry Bird okay
Seton yeah Larry Bird's a good one
that's where I was going all right
Marvin magic oh okay Paulie I would
throw up because he was such a great
defensive player when Clark was in the
pros I'm gonna go Hakeem Olajuwon
I'm gonna go uh I'm gonna go Larry Bird
here let's bring in Clark Kellogg the
former Ohio State Buckeye Indiana Pacer
the best player you played against was
there were a ton of them in the early
80s I got drafted in 82 played only five
years guys really three when you think
number of games because of my left knee
giving up on me as far as playing
basketball but bird clearly is on the
list but the hardest guy for me to
defend
was Bernard King
wow
yeah because he was an unbelievable
scorer had all the shots you needed to
score from
20 feet and in and it seemed like the
Knicks at that time he'll be brown was
coaching them it seemed like they ran 65
of their plays for him
asking him because I think it was around
six five Clark said it was six yeah I'll
give him six six okay six and a half
long arms though so played a little
taller than what he was but man he was
relentless in attacking you and
attacking the basket and I and he I
think he averaged 33 and a half one year
and what I said how do you get your shot
off against bigger guys taller guys he
said he started
to shoot as he's turning around yes he
didn't turn around to shoot no he went
up and turned that's right and it was
rare if you got a piece of of his shot
there
under race quick release yeah very
underrated tremendous score great
tenacity and ferocity when it came to
playing the game and scoring the
basketball so he was a difficult guy for
me to deal with personally Marcus
Johnson was in his Heyday two at that
time and um it was problematic but
hopefully I made it tough for the guys
who had to deal with me for that for
that short time that I was in the league
well you were too nice I'm sure Larry
Bird didn't trash talk you because
you're a nice guy
he was non-discriminate
non-discriminatory in regards
in regards to who God wait what would he
say to you you're one of the nicest guys
on the planet what could like
well I didn't get the brunt of it uh as
I've heard over the years you know get
your hands off of me it's gonna be a
long night you know that kind of stuff
you can't guard me you know and he would
do it like a ventriloquist because you
couldn't see his mouth move
was that because of the mustache
that may have been part of it may have
been part of it but man I will tell you
this I mean we had a game we were you
know we were struggling in the early 80s
hadn't quite got it was right before
Reggie got there in 87 and then Smith's
in 88 and Davis boys I was part of those
teams as a broadcast but never got to
play with Reggie but I retired in 87 but
there was a time when we actually found
a way to beat the Celtics didn't happen
I think we beat him once I hit a last
second shot we played them tough in the
game then hat in in The Quirk of the
schedule sometimes you would play the
same team back to back one time at your
place and then you'd go there and we had
I don't know I don't I don't know if
bird had played well or if he was
frustrated anytime he came back to
Indiana you sensed he was a little more
focused
um but anyway we had played them well
the night before the game before and
then like within a few days we had to go
to the garden and um he proceeded to to
drop 53 on on me and whoever else was
guarding them that night and um I'll
never forget that it was a it was a
different level of focus from one the
greatest players of all time do you
think we'll get somebody scoring 90
points in a game
in the NBA yeah
um yeah I wouldn't say heck I didn't
think we were going to see a 16 beat a
one in the tournament in my broadcasting
career and this happened twice in five
years and so I'm uh slowly but surely
getting to the point where I Won't Say
Never yeah I mean the way the game is
played now Dan I think it can happen I
mean shoot it's going 160 170
um more regularly than in past years so
yeah I think we'll probably see somebody
um approach 93 digits
all right I don't know but but 90 seems
um feasible at some point in the not too
distant future I'm wondering if uh the
blueprint for success in college
basketball is maybe shying away a little
bit more from the one and done
I think you're seeing that [__] I do
because of the transfer portal on the
additional covet year that was added I
think expires next year Dan but it has
created older teams more older players
and some of the players that perhaps
started at the non-power conference
level by virtue of an additional year or
two have become really good college
players at 23 or 24 years old and that
has added to some of the parity we see
and I think you're right because there
are other avenues for guys who really
aren't interested in going to college
and want to get their pro career started
you know with the g-league and the
ignite team so there are other Pathways
if you're not interested in taking the
I do think you're going to see a little
more of that shifting away from um one
and does I think for one there some many
of them will elect to just go straight
to pursuing a pro career like you would
in Europe I mean those young you know
dantich and other guys they've been Pros
well before they got to the United
States I mean at 15 16 years old they're
identified and tapped and tabbed by
clubs and then they begin their Pro
journey and so I think you'll see a
little more of that and as a result you
will see some of what we've um seen over
the last decade and happening it's kind
of been Amplified I think the last two
years part of it is part of it is
obviously the transfer portal talking to
Clark Kellogg CBS sports college
basketball analyst what surprised you
last night
the Brilliance of Marquis Noel was just
something to behold I mean to set a
tournament record with assist in a game
that Michigan State played well enough
um to win on most nights I mean the
turnovers were a problem and they
couldn't Corral Noel and his Brilliance
shine through when it needed to most
um
that was special I don't necessarily
know if it was surprising because he had
been he's been playing that way all
season for the most part he's been
carrying that team he's the Undisputed
leader
um
I tell you what
the play Gonzaga called down one
that was a designated play band that was
not this kid decided to shoot that three
let's hold that place that's the
Villanova trailer play yes that's the
Villanova trailer looked exactly like it
and that kid stepped into it wasn't
thinking about anything else but
stroking that three and that
me and Charles and Kenny were watching I
said they called that play you know it's
just unfolding and he let it fly we're
like what and it just that was that was
mildly surprising to see that play call
not to attack the realm you're down or
you're down there too that they know you
well you've done one or two there you
were down I can't remember I've lost my
mind now I can't remember if it was one
or two they were it was one it was one
they were only down one they were they
went up two when he made it so they're
down one after Amari Bailey had hit that
three but to call that play that was
that was pretty pretty surprising and
gutsy and uh great Theater Great theater
but UCLA did defend it they were ready
for it he he hit the I mean they jumped
out on it yeah but he was waved he was
like right at the he was almost at half
court I mean he was between the top of
the three-point line and the half court
logo and it's really hard to you're
right I think they did reasonably well
defending it but man he stepped into
that thing with great confidence and
what a shot what the game what a finish
what do you expect tonight what would be
surprising to you tonight
wow that's a really good question
um
I don't know what would qualify as
surprising I'm just going to enjoy the
ride because we know and we've already
seen it this year and we've seen it in
past tournaments that they're coming
it's hard to predict where they where
they're going to come from and in what
fashion the surprises but like Princeton
is a 10-point underdog against Creighton
that with that shotgun no it wouldn't
shock me because they are one of the
best rebounding teams in the country
they've got multiple Playmakers and
Shooters and they're playing well you
know you don't luck your way to the
Sweet 16. you need some good fortune on
occasion to win multiple games in the
tournament but the teams that get here
are all capable of winning and advancing
so that wouldn't surprise me I love
Creighton though I love the way they've
recaptured how they played early in the
season you know the first six seven
eight games they were rolling they were
really rolling fun to watch extremely
versatile and balanced offensively play
at a good Pace defensively they've
gotten better particularly with [__]
Brenner in the middle anchoring the
paint form
um they're not very deep basically play
six and a half guys but I I really I
really thought grateful is a dark horse
team to get to Houston as a sixth seed
and they both wait wait they've proven
they're capable they have six and a half
player they don't they have a player
who's a half a player no no no that's
just the fit that's just the figure of
speech oh okay I was thinking you know
because yeah yeah Kansas state has one
of those and it's Marquis Noel he's he
at five eight you know there are certain
guys that defy Logic on the basketball
floor yeah right there there'll be times
you'd go play and you'd go how is that
guy doing what he's doing right yeah
yeah no doubt when I first saw I came
out of high school in 79 one of the
really outstanding perhaps the best high
school class ever with worthy and
Dominique Wilkins and Isaiah Thomas Sam
Bowie and Ralph Sampson Sydney Lowe and
thorough Bailey and Dale Ellis and Dirk
Memphis when I first saw Isaiah Thomas
in an All-Star game I played in
I was like how is this little dude doing
what he's doing
ball handling shot making passing
and I was like my goodness then when I
saw Ralph
it's still seven three man pulling up
pulling up off the dribble
after he had raped the rebound and took
it the left and then pulling up from 20.
I'm like what the heck is this you know
so yeah there are guys when you see them
you're like oh my goodness and it just
has continued to ball KD Steph you know
you can make LeBron combining just
unbelievable basketball skill and Savvy
with uh an unbelievable athleticism and
physical I mean so yeah yeah there are a
lot of guys when you see him you're like
Whoa man but I wonder is Isaiah Thomas
underrated because it seems like a lot
of players don't like him and he played
for the Pistons and they didn't like the
bad boys yeah yeah I mean again you
can't disconnect some personal
feelings towards a guy in terms of how
he'll be discussed but the credentials
are obvious and I tell you in
conversations Barbershop talk talk radio
talk when you start talking about
um
dynamic
great
smaller guys
he's in the head of the class I mean
he's on the short list of the Roll Call
I mean there's no way to deny that why
are you going to put him on it you put
him on a short list what are you doing
you can't put him on a short list
that's part of it I mean again six one
yeah six two we're six one but um
fantastic man marvelous marvelous player
and uh because I'm I'm a little biased
because he's part of my era and my my
high school class and
um and I got to see him up close in
college and then a little bit in the
pros and then we had crossed paths and
some high school all-star games so yeah
he's uh he's clearly one of the one of
the great players of all time and I just
think some
think some short riff because of how
some people felt about him and those
Detroit teams but I'm sure he's he's
reconciled that with a couple
championship rings and Hall of Fame I'm
sure he's he's fine with that he's got a
great place in the game's history that's
for sure how do you explain the Joker
oh my goodness
I can't other than he's marvelous to
watch man um you know I just read an
article not too long ago where they
talked about somebody I think George
raveling yeah coach ravling sent me an
article about how players from that part
of the world have really
made an impact on the game there have
been a number of great players come from
there how they all are trained no matter
how big they become they're trained in
basketball skills all skills footwork
shot making footwork hand handling the
ball passing and that's the way they're
taught the game from when they start
playing and if they end up being 6 10 or
7 feet or six nine they play a style
that's beautiful to watch because it's
so fundamentally
um sound and uh man he's oh my goodness
he's a joy to watch it he's a um he's a
ballerina
uh with a body of an old school Center
and man it's uh yeah he's he's he's
amazing so is Joel embiid yeah that
matter well if you look at the best
players in the game they're not from the
United States
great point right yeah Jonas Luca yeah
yeah Giannis yeah yeah yeah but do you
go backwards you know you had you had
Dirk but you had Manu uh I remember
sharonis marcelonis was yeah marcelona
was one of the person yeah
uh I'm thinking of the other guy to um
yeah the great draws them before it's
tragic yeah early death
um yeah um yeah there were a number of
guys that but now it seems like there's
more of a little proliferation of them
but some of that is just more kids can
see them and emulate them and aspire to
that and make their Mark II going
forward what's it like spending the day
or night with Barkley
oh man it is such a treat man he's just
such a genuinely good guy first and
foremost and he's naturally funny I mean
he's not putting I mean he's naturally
funny he's quick with it very very sharp
knows the game knows people
um a successful business guy I mean he's
just he's a joy to be around he's a joy
to be around there's a mutual respect we
have he and I and Kenny and Greg and
Ernie and Seth the whole crew man we
have a great respect but he's he's
unique man there's just not many guys
like him in terms of genuine humility
graciousness as a superstar celebrity
and uh great humor naturally funny and
um he it's easy and fun to be around and
that's um that's a gift that's a gift
great talking to you again always DP
always great look forward to it man
whenever we get a chance to chop it up
keep doing what you're doing man I
remember you trying to dunk when we went
and did a game when we were working at
ESPN I think you I think you got it over
the rim I think you actually it was kind
of a it was kind of a dirty snow dunk it
wasn't like clean white snow but it was
it was still legit it counts for white
guys though
oh you're qualifying it yeah I was you
know we call that a rub dunk
hey thank you thank I was looking for
terminology that's better yeah a little
rubbed up because I remember we were
shooting around we were at UMass yes yes
yeah and Midnight Madness that had to be
like late 80s right
well Calipari was there yeah yeah
it was like
eight nine yeah 88 89 or 90 right and he
heard that I was uh dunking he came out
of the locker room and he wanted he was
like oh I hear I hear you're you're uh
trying to dunk here I said I'm not
trying I'm Duncan
[Laughter]
Coach Cal they might have had Camby that
year
uh I don't think he had gotten there yet
he he was there in 96 so I don't think
he had gotten there yeah yeah that was
yeah that was well after us yeah okay I
think that might have been Cal's first
year there yeah so I might have been one
of the better players on the floor back
then you could have been yeah you're
very welcome at that time no doubt no
doubt uh great to talk to you again
buddy thank you yeah thanks man Clark
Kelly CBS we'll take a break some phone
calls coming up next